the Steinbrenner Institute here at
Carnegie Mellon that
is
try to support environment
education research activities across
campus has a sea grant program that
helps support activities like solar
splash the sort of calphalon individual
student projects a big driver for the
green practices effort here is to
provide through the way that we conduct
our life on campus the way we manage
energy the way we manage water the main
way we manage waste the types of
buildings we put up to to model through
the way that we be we conduct our life
on campus and get them thinking about
decisions they'll make in their own
personal lives in their professional
lives
you